si hay al menos tres personas muertas
confirmadas en la ciudad rusa de
bélgorod es fronteriza con ucrania y
también han quedado dañadas varias
viviendas tras oírse unas explosiones en
esta localidad estratégica de rusia que
además es fronteriza justamente con la
región de kharkiv que en los últimos
días ha sufrido diversos ataques que se
han recrudecido con la reactivación de
la ofensiva rusa de momento ucraniano ha
confirmado la autoridad de este ataque
aunque en el sur en la ciudad ucraniana
de melitópol el alcalde de esta ciudad
ha confirmado sí que se han producido 30
ataques llevados a cabo por las fuerzas
armadas ucranianas lo que también
indicaría que ahora ya está empezando a
utilizar esos ataques de precisión que
había anunciado en los pasados días por
otra parte en el donbass las autoridades
ucranianas han informado que si hay un
avance ruso en la ciudad de lishui sanz
que es una de las últimas grandes
ciudades de esta zona que no habían sido
tomadas por el ejército ruso y su caída
implicaría que prácticamente rusia tener
el control completo total de esta
estratégica y disputada región ucraniana